you're live chair thank
you uh good evening everyone and welcome
to this Northwest area planning meeting
uh today 6th of December 2023 I PO poize
for the late start I'm afraid we've had
a few technical issues but we are now
fully plugged in and ready to go my name
is councelor Maddy Thompson I'm the vice
chairman of this committee and sitting
in for the chairman councelor Mark
darham there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through we are streaming
this meeting live as well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded when invited to speak please
turn on your microphone speak clearly
referencing a page or paragraph number
when referring to agenda papers and
ensure your microphones remain off when
not speaking finally can I draw your
attention to the notices on the agenda
papers regarding the different levels of
floor within the chamber and advise that
the fire exit is the door behind the top
table members may I draw your attention
to the members update with further
information on the items on the agenda
including specifically item five has
been withdrawn by the applicant so um Mr
Jones can we have the apologies for
absence
please good evening chair we have
apologies for absence from councelors
darham Morgan and wiffin thank you chair
thank you very much right item three is
the minutes it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 8th
of nov member found on pages 7 to 10 are
approved as a true and accurate record
may I take them as red
members okay I so propose could I have a
second please you're too Swift any
matters of
accuracy say can we agree by ENT some of
us already did thank you right item four
is Declarations of Interest I have to
read this I'm afraid to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other registerable
interests and non-reg interests related
to items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded they're
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise through the
meeting
members okay nothing from there okay so
we move on to what would have been item
five our first planning application that
has as I said been withdrawn so the next
item is agenda item six land adjacent to
thornfield pearly Grove cold Norton um
there's a memb update in relation to
this with a note on a change on
paragraph on the trees and the
presentation is Mr Marsh on teams please
when you're ready uh yes would you like
to read out the update uh please do yes
I think that would be helpful yeah it's
only one paragraph So paragraph 5.9.1 on
page 36 of your agenda It should read
the site is bordered by trees
particularly on the Northern side where
is potential for these to be impacted by
the development whilst the council's
free consultant has advised that there
is limited likelihood of direct impact
to retain trees he has highlighted that
the main access route into the site the
root protection areas of a number of
trees of a significant size he has
therefore objected and recommended that
an argricultural impact assessment is
submitted as part of the
application however the access road has
already been approved by the appeal
decision for application 21 00 397 full
which is an extent fullback position it
is therefore unreasonable to require an
AIA prior to determination of the
application not withstanding this a
condition is recommended that requires
separate approval of details and
specifications for Harden soft
Landscaping including planting
details so I'll go into my presentation
yes please thanks thank you
chairman so this is an application for
two attached dwellings on land to the
rear of uh thornfield ply Grove C Norton
uh the proposal follows the
recent appeal which was allowed for a
very similar form of development and as
said out in the report there are a
number of differences which I'll run on
to in a
minute so this is the location of the
application site have shown on Google
Earth it's approximately 670 m to the
east of the village of cold Norton and
there is a a footway along latchington
road which provides access um for
pedestrians into the village the
application site is here outl in red as
you can see is behind the londes
supermarket and existing development on
lington road where I'm pointing my M now
is early Grove which is
the 140 me long Lane that is accessed to
the development from lington Road this
is an oblique View looking to the east
so just reminding this is ply Gro here
thornfield uh and imps camp this
property here the two laboring dwellings
in the road will access road will come
in between the gap between the two and
there'll be involved L of a small
stretch of hedge here and then moving
into the application
side so which is outlined in red on this
land here the usual
way so this is a proposed site layout
plan with the access road I just refer
to rning along the boundary of the site
and the layout includes the planting the
new hedge to separate the two proposed
properties on this plan the previous
approval is outlined in a red dotted
line and you'll see one of the B
differences is the carports which are
now positioned between the two proposed
rings as opposed to in these positions
here to the side um and the buing two
has been rotated slightly further to the
north the reason for that to provide
better views to the to the to the
South um so you can see the long Gardens
the back of the properties on lington
road which are shown on this plan as
well which is a previously approved
scheme with a two dwellings as I've just
described uh and the proposed elevations
you will see in the slide that follow
are very similar the main differences
being the introduction of a dormer roof
on the rear elevations of the two
properties uh and a porch and a number
of bels roof lights this is because
unlike the the approved scheme if you
see here the proposed development
includes the combination in the roof
space so these are the proposed
elevations here for the the two
dwellings which are as I very similar to
those in and also to a joining
development as we'll
see this is the proposed street scene of
the two new
dwellings and the proposed car ports
which they do include a combination of D
with one of the differences is
Introduction of the stairs to provide
access to that combination in the roof
space of those car
ports this is the naing development I
refer to which um property known as NAA
which is to the west of the end of early
Gro so moving on to the site photographs
this is looking along the lington road
to the West with Road situ
here and then looking the opposite
direction the entrance into here on the
right then moving in and changing
seasons we're looking down to the Gage
for thorn Fields along um PE Grove and
that's looking into ply Grove from the
lington
road then once this is into the site
looking back towards lington Road from
early Grove and then you remember when I
pointed out on the a photographs this is
where the access road will come in
between imp camp this is this property
here and for field a new property on the
right which is shown here in this
photograph with the proposed site behind
so moving through there behind this is
the application side you can see here
the countryside to the South and then
this is the um established hro which
forms the rear Garden boundaries to
those properties on lington road and
forms the northern boundar
side um and that is the end of the
presentation if you not have any
question are be happy to answer them
thank you and the recommendation is for
approval sorry recomend sorry
recommendation report is for conditional
approval okay and can I just check that
it's condition 8 covers the matter of
the
trees uh or do you need an or do we need
an extra one in which case do I have to
the as explained the um the inspector
didn't refer to trees in his
consideration of the application and
granted permission this um development
has a very strong fullback position the
commission is only a year old understood
so that's why I explained in the in the
update as to the being unreasonable to
require agricultural impact assessment
but the condition does require a
landscape planting scheme I understand
that um but that's what I was talking
about that um condition eight covers
that um if if if not do we have to do
something different should this be
approved Mr
it's covered okay thanks very much right
sorry about that um members councilor
white thank you madam chairman I have to
say if I'd known that there was only one
item on the agenda I probably would have
um withdrawn this one but I actually
wanted to look into it clearly here
because I've had an awful lot of emails
and phone calls from objectors and I've
also had emails and phone calls from the
applicants so I obviously did know that
it was on an appeal site sorry it had
been subject to an appeal that had been
won so from that case it it can't really
be turned down but I wanted to see what
we could do um to make condition five
more robust and again with the trees
that have already been mentioned because
the neighbors who are in the barns next
door said since the last House was built
there's been a lot more
flooding um so how can we tighten that
up so there isn't more more flooding cuz
obviously the more grassland that we're
concreting over the more of a problem it
is and can we make sure that the
planting is really really robust and
this is what I wanted to debate is how
can we make it better for the residents
that are already there because obviously
they're they're very upset and I know we
are between a rock and a hard place but
what can we do to make the approval
better and I mean I and I also know that
they've already got permission so adding
Dormers Roof lights anything else that's
neither here nor there but it's how can
we make it better for the existing
residents Mr
M require a detailed drainage schem and
we can't require a developer to um make
or improve an already bet bad situation
but what they must do is not make it
worse so that condition we'll make sure
that the um surface water situation is
not made any worse and it you can't
refuse an application on the basis of a
of not not add sorry the application
will address the the drainage
requirements and make it an acceptable
scheme in terms of sustainable drainage
um with regards to the to the planting
again that's a condition which when the
condition comes in obviously we look at
that closy to make sure that the the
planting scheme is is robust thank
you speak um I mean is there is there
any way that we could do I know it's not
in a flood zone but a sequential test or
something just to really drill down on
the discharge rates um
because it is a problem and I I just
want to make it less of a problem as we
can well the reques they're going to
have to submit peration test so it's got
to demonstrate that you know a
satisfactory drainage schem so I'm not
quite sure what you're asking for I
think that the condition does cover the
the requirements for a satisfactory
drainage scheme not making the situation
worse
understood thank you okay any other
member okay well the um recommendation
is to approve do I have someone who will
propose that councilor Sidle seconded by
well Council white SP actually spoke up
as well as okay those in
favor that's unanimous thank you so I
don't need to ask those against um thank
you well that application is approved in
line with with the officer's report and
you will be delighted to hear that item
seven any other business that the
chairman of the committee decides are
Urgent there is none so um members
members of the public officers thank you
everyone involved and I close the
meeting at
7:47 something of a record I think thank
you